What parts of the closing script would you say are the most important to emphasize?
Most important thing with the closing script, Porter, you got to get in and you got to figure
out what drives them. You got to get in and you got to figure out at the very beginning,
why are they doing the business? Because at the end of this, the end of the call,
when they start to waft and they start to shake and they start to, let me call you back,
or I don't know if it's worth it, you can go back to the thing that they said at the beginning
and you can hit back on that. I remember a couple months ago, I had somebody I was talking to
and we dug in, we dug in, we dug in and I found out pretty early on that they were like,
I want to blow up my business because, and this is a real story, because I'm so tired of my sister
not believing in me and every time I go home, she's talking crap about me and saying I'm not
going to make it and I'm on to the next thing and I'm so tired of that and I was able to find that
up front and at the end when there was like, oh, I don't know if this is worth it, whatever,
I reminded this person, I said, dude, how many more family dinners are you going to go to
and have your sister laugh at you? How many more family dinners are you going to go to or Christmas
get togethers you're going to go to where you're the laughing stock of the family, right?
And I knew that's what drove that person and I was able to hit on that and at the end,
and it was like, yeah, you're right, let's do this, let's freaking do this. So the most important part
of the entire script is figuring out what drives them, period, right? Because if you've done the
lead part correctly and sent the leads, you've done most of the selling already. If you've overcome
the objections beforehand like you should have, I mean, that is most important is figure out what
drives them, figure out why they're in business and then you can always at the end, that can be
your thing that you use to close. And guys, do not hop off the phone with a maybe. Somebody
tells you they'll call you back, say, hey, sir, ma'am, I appreciate you, but if it's a maybe,
that's a no for me, okay? I need somebody now. I need somebody that can commit and if this isn't
100%, after I've sent you three to five leads, after you've made money on my lead, if that's the
case, after I've shown you that I'm going to give you these exclusively, I've shown you how I got
the lead, we've spent a couple hours on the phone. If this still is a no-brainer and look at the
numbers that we talked about on the lead value calculator, if it's still not a no-brainer, it's
a no. Because what you're telling me is you are not confident in your ability to close and that is
not somebody I can work with. So if this makes sense, which I think it does and you know it does,
let's do this right now. If it doesn't, then let's know, but I don't do call me back later,
shit. That's not how we roll. You want to do that with the Dish Network guy, that's fine.
The carpet cleaner guy, that's fine. I work with one company and of course, this is going to be
in your own tone. This isn't the douchebag Nick Wood way that he does it. I don't do maybes,
okay? A maybe is a no. It's either yes or no. It's not yes or maybe or no. It's yes and everything
else is a no.